alpine's destructive open borders
madness is hiding in plain sight tonight
because look at your screen new footage
from fox's own bill malugion showing
adult illegal migrants being released
and transported in texas on their way to
the u.s interior and tonight
investigative reporter sarah carter has
an exclusive report with a recently
retired u.s border patrol official who
has blown the whistle on biden's
indefensible border policy sarah she
joins us with more yeah
sean as the border crisis continues to
deteriorate i've been speaking more and
more to senior officials in the border
patrol agency as well as ice here is a
senior border patrol agent who recently
retired and he wants to make clear what
is happening on the border is being
purposefully done by the biden
administration and their hands are tied
behind their backs
let's talk about that what you're seeing
now what are you seeing what i'm seeing
now is something that i
i have never seen before this career is
always ups and downs um
but this
what i see now
is something that i've like like i've
never seen before like i said and the
most concerning thing is
that it's being done on purpose
in my view my opinion before
like
you work under different administrations
and and they have their
feelings and their policies regarding
the border
um
and i i work under obama
the obama administration
and and and there was some issues but
when those issues were confronted and
they were brought up
um
there was a feeling of
oops i got caught let me correct
let me see what uh what i can do
this time around
what i see is
we can bring
politicians down here do our what we
call a dog in pony shows and all that
and
we show them and it's like we keep
screaming it's like
look at this i mean look at our
processing center look at the border
look at the deaths look at all this but
nothing is done it's like they they
double down
and they continue on all we do is
cleaning up
moving people around
uh
with no i think
administration's
policies are they failed policies or are
they policies that are allowing this to
take place this is uh in their view this
is success
this is a successful policy decision i
don't think this is by mistake describe
some of what it's like for them out on
the front lines what is it like when
you're out there with them mm-hmm uh
yeah and and a lot of people think that
border patrols are demoralized because
you know that is definitely one of the
things you know because
we sign up
to protect this border to protect this
nation
and we're not being
allowed to do that but there's another
aspect of this and it's the suffering
that we see
directly because of these policies we
see things that no human should be
seeing should see ever in their lives we
see death we see suffering
and
when this suffering is being brought off
you know brought on by
the very same people that feign so much
concern
about that population
okay
it makes it even worse these policies
like i said
they're
successful for them
because this is what they wanted from
the from the get-go
sean we'll be bringing more of this
exclusive interview
to the viewers but want to stress here
that this a senior official from the
border patrol that had been there for
decades has said that the national
security of this country is at risk that
he wants to get the message out and
he'll explain why when we bring you back
an interview with this anonymous
official with the border patrol aiding
and abetting law breaking if it was
donald trump he'd be impeached and
convicted anyway great report sarah
carter thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else